olá sou mariana e como agora ainda ao
justiça do trabalho na área de educação
trabalho na área de educação e é
precisamente a educação que acredito que
podemos dar um próximo passo para ficar
um passo mais à frente em todos os
passos das nossas vidas
quando eu tinha 15 anos de idade mais ou
menos viva sempre visam inglesas
chamadas primeiro pensado em projeto o
ator jeremy yates que durava e essa ser
inscrito me imenso
os primeiros episódios foram filmados na
universidade de oxford e via imagens
como esta esquentamento inspirada e tem
que ter criado em tahrir para lá deverá
estudar
imagino que até hoje que o cheiro a ver
os filmes do harry potter talvez então
mesmo
o problema é que horas eu era e continua
concentrada das entradas nos se tarefas
mais difíceis e competitivas ter uma
idéia este ano
eu sei muito obrigado
tanto é que há um pequeno problema que
oxford é apresentadas em tarefas mais
difíceis e competitivas e pretendem uma
idéia este ano a ex-esposa oxford diz um
lugar do mundo à frente da entidade
robert está em festa é mas apesar disso
com uma certa arrogância própria da
juventude e chegou a ser utilizado como
uma certa confiança eu sempre tenha tido
ótimas notas vem a seguir é que sempre
pobres ou estudos fui presidente da
associação de estudantes na minha escola
eu realmente achei que ele tem tudo para
conseguir entrar
infelizmente não foi bem assim porque eu
rapidamente perceber que não tinha as
qualidades de grande porte
foi doloroso grosso por contigo ela tem
tudo para conseguir entrar
isso porque essa experiência dura e
difícil ao mesmo os olhos para todo um
conjunto coisas que eu queria trabalhar
todo um caminho que eu treino renos o
futuro à altura dos réus totalidade
tentei ir por esse caminho e hoje
passados 16 anos
com 34 anos eu começo uma das
entrevistadoras de atenção
alguns aqui hoje são precisamente as
qualidades das vivências competências
nós valorizamos em offset e isso porque
eu acho que essas qualidades são
importantes não só na academia luta das
10 escolas da cidade estágios e empregos
mas em todos os campos das nossas vidas
porque essas qualidades podem fazer com
as pessoas mais capazes empilhadas
interessante e essas qualidades que os
homens há uma coisa muito simples é que
o que eu chamo de uma verdadeira
educação e com prazer em ter prejuízo
não estou falando cansado sentindo
normal da palavra no sentido da educação
técnica ou a escolarização da verdadeira
educação é uma coisa muito mais ampla
nunca deixei que minha escolarização e
turismo e educação
pois é eu também não felizmente e mortos
já sabe isso já no século 19
vou tentar falar agora para o tempo faz
empregada e steven fly senhor aqui é um
escritor humorista e ator em inglês que
é muito amigo de nossos dias
também estou no estado topo que a
universidade de cambridge e quando eu
escrevo quando eu escrevi essa
experiência vai estar na sua
autobiografia a cheia é uma ideia muito
próxima daquela que o cio a verdadeira
educação educação é soma daquilo que os
alunos ensina alguns aos outros
nos intervalos entre as palestras e os
seminários
sentamo nos quais são os outros e temos
câncer
respondi que hoje seja voto em redor e
perdemos entusiasmos fizemos grandes
pratos sobre política e religião arte
universo e depois damos pra cama
sozinhos ou acompanhados com a sua
vontade de cada um
se não fosse assim como é que aprendemos
fosse o fosso
como é que passe a vamos nos nossos
pensamentos e parem aqui nas coisas que
a cia a sua verdadeira educação a ideia
que é uma coisa que pode ser transmitida
de aluno para aluno não só do professor
para o aluno
a idéia é ser muito importante partilhar
entusiasmos e ter entusiasmo para frear
e também não temos medo está no cerrado
enganados
fizemos grandes pratos as partes e esta
ideia que nos fica ser necessário
passear os pensamentos é deliciosa e que
significa para mim
associar os pensamentos quer dizer tem
que estar sempre prontos mantermos
opiniões sobre os mais variados assuntos
e também recebemos partilhar comunicar
debater e defender essas opiniões e há
todo um treino nos podem dar nisto nas
escolas e universidades inglesas
existem cursos debates quando bateu
exatamente a mesma coisa do concurso
futebol sad têm de ser passadas a bola
os outros possamos pensamentos idéias e
argumentos
eu já acho que algumas só estranha
tipicamente o mais velho professor senta
à cabeceira da mesa aconteça bons o lado
esquerdo teve agosto a direito e um
esquerdo tem que ser a favor do tema que
é proposto pelo lado direito tem que ser
contra este mesmo tema e tem que
entender essa precisão em tratamento
sempre parece nenhuma com bons
argumentos convicção e se possível algum
sentido de humor eo tema pode ser
qualquer coisa pode ser um tema que tem
a ver com a tonalidade por exemplo o tec
salvar é o melhor evento do ano
este é um mau exemplo que é uma decisão
que só é possível defender
ou então pode ser uma coisa mais
filosóficas em resposta possível como é
melhor ser alegre que ser triste e
aquilo que interessa é pensarmos um
tratamento em voz alta que quer dizer
que a felicidade
será que é melhor pra quem dá pra mim lá
atrás outros etc
os alunos mais ambiciosos de oxford
seiam desculpas do bate viriam de bater
quando políticos economistas e
jornalistas em oxford union uma espécie
de câmera de deputados enquanto pequeno
eu tenho imensa pena não ter tido esses
aí na minha escola quando era mais nova
estresse voltar atrás
o que eu fazia era criar um discurso com
os meus amigos que a comunicação é uma
vantagem enorme enorme eu teria o
dinheiro estar aqui a falar poxa eu sei
que já existe em portugal um almoço
alguém me contou que existe uma coisa
chama até os cineastas da exatamente
estranho funciona também a quem agora e
recomendo vivamente procura e tals
inácio se o custo gênero
felizmente nunca é tarde demais de
atendê los
aliás essa é outra mensagem que eu quero
estar aqui hoje ganhe sempre atento como
sendo muito mais sábio que todos nós um
guru deixe viva como se fosse morrer
amanhã aprenda com sua se viver para
sempre
infelizmente hoje temos o mundo inteiro
na ponta dos dedos as coisas incríveis
como ajudam a aprender como se fosse um
direito para sempre nos livros e na
internet
uma pessoa na índia agora pode assistir
a palestras seminários e cursos inteiros
a mãe da universidade de oxford oxford
eu acho que
é o nono comove imenso
acho que isso não quer dizer muito mais
importantes que eu já assisti na minha
vida e um recurso muito interessante
emergentes é uma arma chamada haitian
gil que é uma aplicação por exemplo de
cortar esses conteúdos universitários em
vez de músicas ou filmes também focando
recomendo vivamente que seguem essa apto
para jogar os nossos norte santos já
vimos que todos tenham uma acção que vai
ter uma idéia a página de oxford night
surgiu foi criado há cinco anos atrás e
tem os 20 milhões de visualizações 20
milhões de visualizações
quer dizer que esta fome pela verdadeira
educação existe hoje em dia porque é o
sexto caso às vezes não ficar sempre
pensava computador e os livros também
tentou e até leste astúrias e direitos
como esse acho que é importante procurar
um sabor da educação informativa estão
todos de parabéns por estarem aqui
porque já estão um passo à frente só por
terem vindo
educação também passa a focar as novas
experiências
ela é nós em três se consta inglaterra
muito seguras ter um ano sabático entre
a escola ea universidade mas não basta a
este ano inteiro sem fazer nada na praia
tem ar só até porque não há muito sol em
inglaterra
em vez disso que os fazem procuram novos
desafios nas viagens incríveis fazem
muitas vezes sozinhos com pouco dinheiro
um pouco dinheiro conseguem ter e as
toxinas
um amigo meu por exemplo foi ensinar
inglês durante os seis meses que não
estejam diretamente o ano sabático e
nessa altura eu era o único estrangeiro
meu amigo é o único que não estava
sentindo em casa
o perfil que essa aventura achar que ser
uma experiência gira o novo desafio sem
dúvida mas sem grandes consequências
para a sua vida mas acontece que essa
viagem por acaso mudou a sua vida porque
eu gosto tanto tivesse na sua cultura
com só estudar as sessões e nunca mais
parou é hoje um dos grandes
especialistas em busca de uma nova
aventura acabou por descobrir aquilo que
realmente o realiza em portugal também
sei que há cada vez mais pessoas
procuram estilo viagem de experiências
também ótimos recursos podem ajudar
organizá-las existe por exemplo a gata
portugal costume existe e essas viagens
não só para estudantes é claro mais à
frente pode ser mais difícil ter
humildade e vontade mas não é
completamente impossível e muitas vezes
essas experiências podem ser tão
transformadora esqueçam faísca
necessária para uma mudança de carreira
outra vertente da verdadeira educação
que eu não posso deixar de freira é a
nossa participação na sociedade nosso
compromisso social
há duas semanas atrás tive uma sorte
poder assistir a uma palestra matthieu
ricard em lisboa e manter o ricardo é um
filósofo francês e também monstro lista
que começa agora a estudar os efeitos no
cérebro com a ajuda de neurocientistas
do altruísmo pela preocupação e trabalho
com o próximo trabalho voluntariado e
gostar descobrir e está provado
cientificamente é 4 isso no trabalho
voluntariado fazem nós mais fluxo está
provado cientificamente e para além
disso quando desenvolvemos com o mundo à
nossa volta fazendo trabalho voluntário
e asa também ficamos mais plenos mais
completos
todos ganham é o que os ingleses chamam
de uma situação o m muito totó
todos ganham com isso e é por isso o
compromisso social e trabalho do
voluntariado
são coisas tão
risadas em oxford e também cada vez mais
pelas duas empresas nos estados unidos
muitas empresas privadas de uma semana
inteira de férias aos seus colaboradores
todos os anos para que possam fazer
trabalho de voluntariado e continuam a
pagar os salários durante essa semana
concluirá daquilo que eu aprendi ao
longo do meu percurso e daquilo que se
vive hoje em dia o nível de educação ao
mais alto nível o voto a favor da
educação está ao alcance de todos e ela
passa a meu ver que os tópicos que vos
aqui passar primeiro prendemos associar
os pensamentos
temos que aprender a pensar a bandeira
partilhar as entrevistas de admissão em
oxford eu não estou minimamente
interessada em saber o que é que o aluno
candidato já sabe eu quero tentar
perceber como é que eu penso eu
realmente interessa aos mais variados
assuntos e sabe a procura da verdadeira
educação por ela fundada em 3 que já
temos e explorar os novos em três
procuraram experiências novas e
finalmente seu compromisso social com
portuguesa que trabalha em oxford
ainda mais estando aqui em outra grande
cidade universitária de dizer que
acredito mesmo que estejamos todos na
verdade a educação e quando de todos
quer dizer cada um de nós mas as nossas
escolas mais as nossas necessidades e
professores mais as nossas empresas e o
nosso país é aquilo que nos pode ser um
passo à frente para todos os próximos
fácil
obrigado